at that point there's another coyote in
the sidewalk the way I just come another
in the street they are surrounding me
just standing there who are you hi I'm
Christian Harrison here is an old friend
we've known him for years
Christian brought some really crazy AR
prank
technology into the office Roman come on
that wood product here just a normal
innocent poker chip you put it on your
hand in its track tracked it and it's
able to kind of either onto your hand
this AR feel of a spider being on your
hand
yeah well the prank part of it though is
a little sleight of hand involved prop
spider with a sticky when your position
in it you just kind of stick it there
and they don't even feel it so then when
you tell them it's on your hand close
the doughnut and get it out and then you
tell them to put it back on their phone
that's why you're scared now you know
who's going to really really enjoy this
I live near the mountains up in like
Glendale being in the mountains what's
like wild animal I was walking my dog
last night and all of a sudden Odie
starts pulling at his leash like
hardcore one to go if you saw another
dog or a squirrel like I'm like less
weird and that's why I notice this is a
coyote in the sidewalk just standing
there about six feet from where Obie
with standing I'm like oh hello coyote
normally this is why coyotes run away
they're very skittish mostly a little
bit large from OB but this coyote was
easily three or four times large it was
like maybe up to my knees I walk around
the corner and I see two more I see
standing in the sidewalk staring at one
comes up from behind a car and another
comes out from behind a house and so now
there's five coyotes in my path scaring
yet i might just turn around go back
this way
okay at that point there's another
coyote in the sidewalk the way I just
come another in the street and then
another out in the the intersections I
was at a corner three coyotes and then
five coyotes they are surrounding me
returning you know I don't think the
counties are trying to me but I have
heard stories from them chasing down
dogs who are on leashes okay
okay I pick up Oh II kinda don't know
what to do but there's those five
coyotes Mike all right just one please
scattered immediately I was like okay
good but now I feel a little involved
I kept chasing chasing you coyotes down
the street oh we like you while the
Coyotes are scattering everywhere one
goes across the lawn Clark's pooping in
the lawn staring at me Emily this big
guy is poppin school I look in over his
shoulder everything across the street
like I dare you pinches would often
takes off running I had never
experienced that before that was easily
the most coyotes I've ever seen the
largest coyotes and I've never seen them
that focused before okay it's time to
talk about audible I'm using this as an
excuse to talk about one of my favorite
books and this book is called Miss porn
it's from my favorite author Brandon
Sanderson and it's actually the first
trilogy this one being the final Empire
it is a fantasy novel with one of the
coolest magic systems I've ever
experienced it's a cross between Harry
Potter Game of Thrones and attack on
Titan imagine a world where everyone is
oppressed by an evil dictator who is
essentially immortal and has been in
power for a thousand years people try to
kill him before he stabs isn't Slade
burned alive decapitated he always grows
his body back this / in particular
actually follows the efforts of a crew
of speeds they're tired of the caste
system that pits the nobility versus all
the pencils and book the cops got but
they're all just like Holocaust levels
with just like ooh who wouldn't want to
live there that's fertile everyone die
they decide to take on the suicide
attacks of killing the Lord ruler and
toppling the final Empire but this is a
suit
title test that is about as impossible
as it sounds but in this world there are
people with special abilities and
they're very rare but every now and then
a person will snap away with one of a
selection of different powers these
people are called missing and they can
have powers such as the ability to have
better hearing and eyesight or the
ability to enhance their body except
they have more strength and better
balance or even the ability to influence
the emotions around them but what's even
more rare is when a person snaps with
all of the power and those people are
called Mistborn they are so dangerous
and lethal they're essentially one-man
army that are two main characters in
this book are miss borne miss born are
so lethal because of this other set of
abilities called metal pushing so we can
either push metal away from you or pull
metal towards you so for things like
coins we like but the issues there is
that if the piece of metal is too big or
stuck you have to move instead so
completely against a piece of metal that
is like huge
you don't apply what that means is that
a simple coin suddenly becomes either a
weapon or a transportation device in a
super cool because you can like push a
coin into the ground and you go flying
up into the air so what so now coins the
kulluk and that's why I love this series
so much because anderson created this
magic system that like obeys the laws of
physics somehow whoa oh and this series
has like the coolest set of villains and
they're called steel inquisitors and
they have these massive like foot long
metal spikes pressed through their eye
sockets out the back of their head
they're very mysterious and very creepy
but they have all the same abilities as
a Mistborn but they're more power or
they have these black axes but they like
to just be head everyone around them but
when steel inquisitive Miss borns start
fighting it's so cool audible itself has
like this unmatched collection of
audiobooks I listen to it every day on
my way to work on walk all kind of stuff
it's great I highly recommend it I
just legitimately infatuated with the
service thanks for watching guys thanks
to audible for sponsoring this video if
you want to get your 30-day trial and
get this book for free you can go to
audible.com slash Sam and Nico and once
you get really into it read all the
books you become as hardcore as Hannah's
I am they are thing that Christian has a
are thing yeah do you're speaking my
language so you got to hold this chip
for example we have the ability work to
the pastor oh my gosh it I know your
little few different funders with to pay
our doors as they are playing how I
handle it should i watch the watch is so
specific we're gonna mess the track up
ready now I'm playing your track yeah
totally ready oh my gosh so wait wait
they thought they'd come let it crawl
around a little bit
give it stop it I'm gonna get out
kuleana would we answer this we gotta go
again
now watch with crazy technology now
yellow we don't kick it into my slump
put it into my car put this chip over
put it in back in my care that bad and
it's because it isn't that bad we're all
right we say what we got a little bit
I'll give you first day too and all I
figured it was a fun little birthday
prank I kicked the wall my toes in the
log hell that was good pretty cool I
should've seen that coming cuz I've seen
this prank before I just now realized
that was food I'll give you guys welcome
to the king prison that was that was
true word
wall I like how you read into the wall
there was like a combination of overhead
hands with with shaking at the same time
that is like a job
generally the [ __ ] bow dropkicks job
I didn't I didn't hit my head have you
ever heard of like augmented reality
[Music]